to another successful mission I couldn't
do I do without you in my earpiece head
down the tunnel
you got three coming in you imagine me
with a gun what these look delicious
COO this is very chewy you're eating a
hand towel just cleansing my palette
hooray join the CIA thought I was gonna
be this amazing spy I'm just the same
boring person I was before you play it
too safe I just hear my mom's voice give
up on your dream Susan just to write
that in my lunchbox rayna boyanov is
about to sell a tactical nuclear weapon
to a terrorist organization told you to
send me in net you can't
she knows the identity of all our agents
we need someone to find a bomb without
being detected I'll do it okay thanks
lunch lady you're going okay yeah bring
one of your cats as a sidekick I don't
have cats go see Patrick he's got
special equipment for you you'll be
given a new identity
Oh cat lady missing a shirt that says
I've never felt the touch of a man
the confidence builder you really think
you're ready for the field to leave the
action tonight not to make direct
contact with any of the targets a real
spy Owens drove a car off a freeway on
top of a train while I was on fire not
the car I was on fire I'm starting to
freak me out poor little pathetic Susan
my father used to bring people here you
also make you dress like a [ __ ]
dolphin trainer did I forget to knock no
are you you want me to have Cagney and
Lacey explain to you Cagney is gonna
come up your ass like a thunderbolt and
shoe off both your Swedish meatballs you
can cry I'm not gonna cry I'm not
you really think you're ready for the
field what do you suppose